il était la vedette de la caq lors de la
dernière campagne électorale il ya un an
et demi et bien jacques duchesneau vient
d'annoncer sébastien qu'il ne se
représentera pas aux prochaines
élections dans saint girons oui le coeur
n'y est simplement plus pour monsieur
duchesneau un choeur mise à rude épreuve
par les frustrations du travail des
députés monsieur duchesneau dit que les
idées de la caq ont été volés reprise
par d'autres partis la période de
questions et n'est pas une période de
réponse et ça c'est très frustrant
écoutons monsieur le chien
la première journée j'avais un cahier
père prend des notes 12h ce qu'il va se
passer des choses j'attends toujours
période des questions ou dans lequel on
n'a jamais de réponse c'est tellement
décevant je vous dis quand je vous
disais ma tête a réagi d'une façon mon
coeur d'une autre façon s'est rendue je
pense physique je suis incapable surtout
souvent les réponses qui sont posées on
connaît les réponses on n'a jamais de
réponse je peux pas vous imaginer
comment c'est frustrant pour moi voilà
alors voilà pour la vie carrière courte
carrière politique de monsieur
duchesneau
campagne électorale toujours parce qu'il
y aura une campagne on doit se
précipiter pour voter des projets de loi
celui sur mourir dans la dignité bien et
ça m'a pas là le temps va manquer pour
adopter ce projet de loi auquel pauline
marois est en fait tous les
parlementaires tiennent parce que à
cause du calendrier électoral le parti
québécois pousse sur les partis
d'opposition pour l'adopter une seat
demain soir or les libéraux en
particulier 10 c'est un sujet très
émotif très important il faut que nos
députés puissent s'exprimer sur la
question et on n'aura pas le temps de
passer la quarantaine de députés
libéraux qui veulent s'exprimer
véronique hivon la ministre responsable
implorent les partis d'opposition de
collabo
raison juste en train d'y il me semble
qu'on est capable encore de faire ce
petit polo qui va nous amener ou fil
d'arrivée et qui je pense vont redonner
beaucoup d'espoir et beaucoup de
confiance aussi dans la population
alors on verra ce qu un miracle peut
survenir c'est toujours des miracles
possible et puis rapidement le parti qui
est le parti libéral et la caq veulent
convoquer madame marois et son mari en
commission parlementaire sur la question
du deal of la ftq et claude blanchet le
mind pauline marois les parties
répulsion lâche pas le morceau alors il
ya une motion qui présente et qui
devrait être adopté demain convoquant
pauline marois et claude blanchet en
commission parlementaire le 10 mars
prochain est-ce que ça va forcer madame
marois a changé son calendrier électoral
pour ne pas comparaître en commission
parlementaire l'avenir nous le dira
parce que les élections pourraient être
convoquées donc déclencher le 10 ou le
11 ou élève à la reprise ou non avant
merci sébastien